one of our producers came across this on
the st. Louis post-dispatch apparently
the KKK is putting out flyers in this
town outside of st. Louis saying you can
sleep tonight because the KKK is
watching her may have hotline numbers
thank you for calling the traditionalist
American Knights at the Ku Klux Klan
we're unapologetically committed to the
interests and values of the white race
we are determined to maintain and enrich
our cultural and racial heritage white
people will simply not by the Equality
propaganda anymore and have begun to
doubt some of the anti clan hysteria
that they have been said in school and
from TV and movies the traditionalist
American Knights of the Ku Klux Klan is
simply a movement of white people for
the highest standards of Western
Christian civilization there's gonna be
an AJ plus team on the ground in
Ferguson this weekend covering events as
they unfold check us out
one more download the AJ plus mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your App Store now